[Music]
in fake rejection news don't say no say
oh submitted by the Armenian Joseph
oh it's like a Harrier me a college
student wins over $250,000 in court
after his ex-girlfriend tried to ruin
his career
oh I saw this [ __ ] [ __ ] shitty
ex-girlfriend tell us rap career I don't
know what type but it was like oh you
should be going to this university but
she's like no I want you to stay with me
but it was like she's with me so she
like I'd like to fame him kind of like I
ruined his reputation probably she
wanted him to be close to her I just saw
this meme I didn't read the story also
all I saw was her picture his picture
and then it was he was awarded two
hundred thousand something don't know
anything is what you're telling us
because she ruined his chances that's
exactly what the I saw the picture geo
picture I read I read the caption under
me and I thought it was only a mean I
thought you knew more beyond the title
dude yeah we all just heard that we're
all on the same page now thank you Joe I
know one step ahead yeah go ahead
she's Asian he like whoa there's CSE
right at least he's right okay can we
hear the real story now all right so the
real story is there's this guy named
Eric 24 years old from Canada he is a
serious musician who plays the clarinet
I knew as a musician he's now an elite
serious clarinet player got a [ __ ]
picture like this busy but where does he
play in an orchestra somewhere I know he
does yeah okay so that's the only
feasible it's true cuz I never heard of
a clarinet solo solo a clarinet solo a
solo solo clarinet
yeah the habitants unlike Kenny what is
Kenny G play I know
soprano saxophones that makes my but
that's but that's how my head was it and
clarinet do you know why that's jazz
though but in like symphonies and like
classical music
there's clarinet solos yeah so the
orchestra or a symphony nobody hears
that [ __ ] her home has told me that [ __ ]
yeah see that's exactly what I pictured
oh my god I have this action shot of him
[ __ ] like going to town is the
equivalent of a [ __ ] rock star going
like this and [ __ ] interesting you could
just tell by somebody's hair how hairy
their body is I've seen a lot of guys
that have thinning hair but then they
have crazy 5 o'clock shadow like crazy
and also tapping this guy his treasure
has never touched his skin it's [ __ ]
floating Babu got hair like bedsprings
that [ __ ] like a [ __ ] [ __ ] axe
ok so this is Jennifer [ __ ] I know
you
Shadia JK fan guys I don't care so that
guy might be a JK
like the Asian girl I waste my porn on
all the time good Wow wait wait let's
talk about that you know like because
like nowadays remember I told you guys
recently I saw porn for a very specific
reason and you know like you you
filtered through all this porn a lot of
us that amateur [ __ ] now and they all
look like that you waste your and so you
click it cook it when I used to watch
porn more avidly there was a lot
prettier girls yeah like just and it's
like in a weird bedroom like that now
they took over the porn yeah you all
look like amateur like blurry [ __ ] is
like a popular thing now nobody told me
about this [ __ ] it wasn't very fun flute
player she's also a very serious
musician so they met at the same school
she looks like she's trying to [ __ ]
blow out a birthday candle that was a
flute player yeah
no it's about what is it what what the
[ __ ] it doesn't matter what the
materials you play the flute yeah for
real I just said I play the last chair
[ __ ] fools been tiny in your big ass
what's this one that was a little small
the recorder no no I mean this one G oh
oh that's because my teacher told me
this was a float for you boots that
ex-girlfriends name is Jennifer and I'm
hauling her out Jennifer come on Lee I
knew it that's my second guest rapper
she look Korean Jennifer Lee that's my
second grade Korean or Chinese Chinese I
didn't really see everything Korean this
is when Asians like no you take her no
you [ __ ] take on about her I think I
just go here because she got that bench
[ __ ] but but if she got that like
thought that Chinese family that cares
about like prestige and [ __ ] like that
then those [ __ ] turn out real bad and
that's when they hook on to the
boyfriend
I think she's Chinese because she got
that Chinese fob room in that picture oh
okay when Asians do something great like
every
he tries to claim them like I don't want
like [ __ ] stuffed animals let's
[ __ ] colors
she looks Korean too though no that is
not Korean dude Oh Shay I'll tell you
guys their nose looks not Korean yeah
that's one that's totally not tell you
do okay furniture doesn't look Korean to
me either
yep it smells like mom I have to wait
for people do what you want to say tell
me I'll say it oh yeah you're better you
should do this I'll shout over everyone
nothing is quite enough okay so Eric had
been training since he was 7 years old
for nearly news entire like whoa for
this opportunity which is to study under
one of the best clarinet teachers on the
planet on a full ride scholarship to
Colburn Conservatory of Music in Los
Angeles
Chozen clearly Jedi and he was being
taught by the clarinet [ __ ]
Yoda of all the Yoda teacher he was only
accepting to students for this bull ride
he was one of them was back in Maisie
he doesn't want that many students know
what a lazy bastard are for free the
other ones are paying he's only two full
ride seats I don't know it's up to you
to if he's lazy or not I don't know so
anyway this guy's name is EULA Gil
doughnuts Yuda
[Music]
the Armenian Yoda hey he was great you
would have messed you bad you will play
yeah it's Wow oh yeah good job do yeah I
heard it she said you the best yeah
anyway so that's the teacher right and
so so apparently Eric so anyway so she
hacked into Eric's email because he left
his email on his facebook open they live
together he had a lot of trust she
hacked into the email she created a fake
email account wallet where the teacher
and she sent a rejection letter to Erin
and she also rejected the scholarship
with the teacher oh oh so she was
jealous that she didn't get the you to
respond
that's a flute player he's a clarinet
seat what's the difference I don't know
a different instrument at the point this
is this way absolute this way
point is you didn't want him to leave oh
I thought she was jealous of his success
no because though are you Canada and
this would be in LA were they already
ex-boyfriend no they're together they
had two huh well he would have to leave
Canada and go to LA yeah
how good is they could have still been
together not in her eyes though yeah
horizon Eric says like Hugh just was
numb when he read the email yet to read
a few more times he went through some
super dark sad angry days I would have
cry like a little bit that was his whole
life yeah but then like in the rejection
letter she even like she had the teacher
make an offer to him to like lessen the
blow of the rejects the rejection was
which was to give him a spot at the
University of Southern California with
$5,000 Canadian dollars a year which
would be too expensive for him to afford
so he had to obviously reduce old
copulating yeah yeah like [ __ ]
calculated whoo that sounds Korean as a
[ __ ] yeah just a little bit man
a little bit little [ __ ] kiseki
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah so she he's so he
decided to
they at that same school to finish his
his degree man he must have real good
dick that's what I'm thinkin dude that
[ __ ] fuzzy ass dick pipe cleaner dick
he's gonna find another clarinet
probably like a cat Taylor [ __ ] there's
like go ahead pull the back
so then six months after that whole
rejection thing they ended up breaking
up because things were working out and
then Oh so he decided he was still
determined to study under that
particularly for him so he decided to
audition for a place at USC where he was
teaching after he graduated already he's
auditioning there he's like I felt this
tension in the room it was kind of weird
and obviously he felt the weirdness
because he got rejected so he thought
beautiful what's going on so then that's
when the teacher was like why are you
here and the dude was like oh well I
mean I know you rejected me but I wanted
audition he's like no you rejected me
and so that was kind of weird so he was
like oh that's weird
and then they started making now she's
like why didn't you write the letters
he's wrong they're like I wrote you
letters every single day yeah she was
like what whole time anyway so he was
offered another full scholarship and he
was awarded a position a USC certificate
program and began studying under him
hell yeah gonna be obviously more
expensive
well eyeballing him like I wanted you as
my [ __ ] disciple and you
rejected me [ __ ] like you don't only
take two disciples and you reject me so
then a feeling I would never do such a
thing and then they [ __ ] make down
they make doubt they make that so then a
few months later one of that teachers
former students approached Eric after
performance and said why didn't you
study here at colburn when you had the
chance and then that's when Eric was
like what the heck like how come
everyone's saying that I rejected this
it's so small that they talked about it
that's so and so dejected no one's ever
rejected but it's literally like
somebody giving you a million dollar
saying no and this is the cream of the
crop so I think there's only like
handful of people at the industry that's
a coveted position yeah that's like
Beck's like no one ever rejects yeah
Kobe yes a better chance to play
basketball with them we got we got it
when you said Kobe Kobe beef okay and he
was able to trace that fake email or if
you tried to trace that fake email but
there was no luck and then that's when a
friend finally suggested what about Jen
like you lived with her she had access
to your computer she could've easily
done all this oh that means that Fred
didn't [ __ ] like her ever I don't
know but that's when Eric you would
never suspect tried to hack into email
he tried different passwords that she
would have used and finally one of them
unlocked that email account and such was
what Jen and Harry forever like a movie
Eric best isn't Jen and Bucky bets
brings rare Eric sued Jennifer for
$300,000 in general damages including
loss of reputation loss of education
opportunity and loss of two years of
petition the judge tacked on an extra
fifty thousand against Jennifer for her
despicable interference in his career
this is one of the lawsuits that I feel
really good because he actually sued for
a reasonable amount yeah sort of for a
million that's what those Canadians do
man they sue for reasonable amounts this
was in LA that's 20 million they
actually feel for the victim because
they're not a sue-happy society yeah I
want to show you photo of Eric now with
his current girlfriend I mean from this
angle and then I'm gonna play she's a
pretty girl I'm gonna play a clip of an
interview he did yeah he's hilarious fun
this is possibly the most disturbing
thing that she was the one who was there
like consoling me you know she was the
shoulder that lit that I was leaving
that [ __ ] is insane fact that she was
the one that did
you you were trouble when you walked
there I just can't believe that someone
cannot have an overwhelming amount of
guilt just you know lying to someone
betraying someone like that how is he
smiling I know cuz he's like three
hundred thousand dollars Richards oh
yeah that's I knew you were trouble but
I mean they've been broken up for years
already to at this point because he
really finished college
oh damn and then she was just like well
he doesn't know I ruined his life
anyways yeah what up conniving evil hell
what the so where is this girl now
that's what I want to know pink and now
he's watching this episode is what's
happening cuz she's a fan we don't want
you go away I do [ __ ] dick he turn it
off that just means she's a hardcore
we're cutting now if you don't watch it
I bet you're happy we made part of his
hairy ass aren't you you go away we're
leaving you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]